the best restaurants don't have
bathrooms that's the key that's what
I've learned it I'm making worth it
today we are on our way to Las Vegas and
what is Vegas known for buffets guys I'm
intoxicated by the sheer volume of food
that we have consumed on this trip so we
just took a little nap
you took a nap everybody else was the
human about it we all spoon today we're
gonna need three different types of that
three different price points to find out
which one is the most worth it at its
given price point today we're gonna
start off with the expensive taco
because there's an expensive taco in Las
Vegas so we're going from high to low
yes and then drive back to LA try the
medium in Chi poppin yeah I'd rather
just go home first take a nap another
nap are you one of those people that
just takes a bunch of little nips during
the day instead of actually sleeping be
like a hamster person so we're going to
the road's rabbit lie they got lots of
live entertainment but also a 4700 is it
one taco that's me best truffles is it
one taco Oh No
[Applause]
asou my name is brian filer i'm the
hotel executive chef for the
Cosmopolitan of Las Vegas and we're
standing in Rose rabbit light right now
it's a modern supper club that serves
American classics kind of revamped so
you guys ordered the Osetra caviar taco
this is served from the Osetra sturgeon
which is a more rare species so Osetra
has a really nice creaminess to it a
little bit briny but just really smooth
finish so the first thing is obviously
the base the taco shell which is made
from the Kennebec potatoes so we thinly
sliced those and then we fry them here's
a little piece of equipment to make them
into a simple taco shell look and then
we'll take the hamachi we do a nice dice
of that shallots cucumbers mix all that
together and then season it lightly with
a little bit of salt pepper and a lemon
vinaigrette and then we'll put that into
the taco shell top it with a nice amount
of caviar and then finish it with the
uni creme fraiche so it's really just a
really nice one biter oh it's a one
biter yeah yeah go big or go home the
best way to taste caviar is to actually
get the caviar onto your tongue and then
press it against the top of your mouth
so you can feel the eggs kind of pop and
then you can spread that creaminess and
those flavors across your palate pretty
steep price for taco which actually now
looking at it is very tiny you want to
come out and impress somebody you're
paying for great product ro try the line
there's a weight chance
I like this it's a lot smoother easier
to drink I think it's delicious I can't
wait to taste it with the caviar feel
like normally someone else does that
because I would be too clumsy and
probably mess it up this is the cutest
food I've ever seen it's one of pinches
cheeks you know usually we debate on how
fast we eat these things but here we're
forced to eat it in one bite
we're not for us but we recommend it I'm
not gonna not do the recommended thing
when it's a forty seven dollar talk on
the line a lot of pressure Cheers ready
go
Olek rock wow I've never had an ocean
taste like that I've never been so sad
that there wasn't a second bite I think
this is like the closest thing to draw
hugs I've ever eaten
done in my life how do you come here and
not just order another I was expecting
like a stink you know when you think
about caviar even like this she or
stinky that was not any of that it was
so pleasant in the way that it just
melted in my mouth
did you pop the balls on the roof of
your mouth of course yeah you got it
with your tongue yes tasting it while
chewing at the same time mmm
that was cabby art what's a pirate's
favorite seafood I know happy our next
place let's go
so time to go back to Los Angeles to try
the next two tacos movie magic will be
in LA shortly back in sunny LA it's
raining recycle was fun it's like
knowing you're young you want to just
experience life and spend lots of money
and not really make commitments that's
what that taco what do you know that
feeling I have never known that thing
I'd want to be married since I was born
next we're going to is guisado they
serve stew base taco taco time are you
ready to talk about it are you ready to
either talk over the town taco the town
national image did you hear the first
one I made that was not bad nice he got
better what's up guys welcome to
Gustavus I'm Armando della Torre jr. my
father and I own if you saw this and
operate them you saw this means to be
braised or stoop so everything we do is
been stupid multiple ingredients that
your Chios are handmade 100% corn the
corn is fresh ground next door my
uncle's markets called incognito so drop
on they make pan dulce tamales and masa
is all made right here so like what
we're doing here is they're making the
masa fresh all of what's cooking here is
what used tomorrow Accord is steeped in
these large vats after it's absorbed
enough water the skin of the corn comes
off they grab that corn and put it into
a stone grinder which grinds that corn
down into like a doughy texture ours are
thick enough that they can handle like
the juices and all of the sauces that
come on our tacos we're gonna give you
my favorite chicken my favorite pork my
favorite veggies the chicken one is our
mole day I took poblano style so it's
got peanuts in it and a bunch of
different seasonings as far as the pork
goes they're gonna give you our coaching
if FPV it's actually a pace that you
cook into the pork and the pork leg
slowly falls apart we serve it shredded
a little bit of habanero to kick it up
and then pickled onions and then the
galavis eat us and squash tomatoes corn
onions and all
we top it off with a little bit of
Chipotle cream and Gessle fresco on top
our menu itself is not one particular
state or city of Mexico it's like things
that you would imagine like your grandma
cooking at home here we go here we go I
got the or Tata whit I got the Armando
Palmer can we throw all this is super
refreshing this is super awesome when he
started talking about do face meets I
did not expect them to turn out in this
pretty all right so we're starting with
this one we're just chicken same ole way
which is a really dank sauce I already
know the pot I'm going to use what is it
we'll see it at first doctor truck
telephone cheers Cheers
holy moly and that's completely accurate
this chicken is perfectly cooked in this
sauce it's like a hot cocoa on the top
that's a perfect taco look sure on the
bottom nothing seeping through sporting
together so well how do you make chicken
taste like that just do it
Center it up tacos all right to the
veggies now I probably would never order
this on my own volition I have no idea
what it's going to taste like gonna
taste like your jokes corny we already
did that
[Music]
delightful I was expecting a salad under
tortilla but it was so much more than
that there's a whole lot of different
vegetables happening together playing
off of each other you bring your
vegetarian friends here and they're not
gonna be neglected they won't be
neglected but they won't have as much
fun I'm always having fun better you're
not alright here we go the last last but
not least are you gonna be spicy my
mouth is but my bud it's not it's better
than isn't get it over with this point
[Music]
Wow
that's my favorite look at the
cross-section on that bad boy
mine's rental in his Russian right now I
mean the pickled onions the stew the
pork and the onions are so sharp wow
that's a dead [ __ ] oh my face is
sweating this is the true definition of
flavor explosion yeah that flavor
exploded in my mouth this is dynamite
you take a bite a great flavor you burst
out and then the spice hook chokes on it
is that good this was a total body
experience
it was really spicy huh I would eat
there every day it's affordable it's
familiar and it was delicious
it's perfect taco facts tacos alpha
store were created by the influence of
Lebanese immigrants in Mexico I guess
that makes a lot of sense because it's
like the way they do the meat is just
like you would do it if you were making
kebabs I really like this fact this
might be one of the best facts you've
ever given on this show are you
complimenting me I'm really more
complimenting the effect and now to the
final destination very well known for
their outpost or tacos $1.00 tacos
they're not exactly those dollar 25 al
fester tacos Leo's tacos iconic la taco
truck we are in taco heaven
we're in taco town forget it Steve it's
taco
[Music]
[Music]
yeah cuando cuando se puede parada
enemas pero lo que lo hace distinct Sao
lo que le das sabor lo que le de lo que
somos el tipo del Quon Demento que una
le fond de tacos al pastor a son Nick o
porque en una preparation especial a
Celtic okay Alana code o con el que
sirve emos Pina ya todo de ma cell
service totake anima we're goin save our
sin cara de minimis amma
Papa's can't wait to try to tacos yeah
eat dining is kind of however you want
it at this place
eat how you please here after two days
eating tacos in two different cities
we've come to the cheapest couple
experience to do that yeah we're
actually at a gas station
mmm do yours please alright alright
Cheers
that is so good it's so simple it's
carpet it's just like a little bite of
sweet on a pile of perfectly spicy mean
it's just three agrees that just
perfectly balance each other you're me
Victoria and the Chris pineapple covers
you see I'm in love with how the
pineapple just like cuts through it's
always shining there a little brilliant
sweet and bite it's like a simple food
that leads to a simple joy that pathway
to joy is so straight from an alpha
store Taco the LR 25 to my mouth to my
heart I think we're just gonna get more
tacos
we did it we had a bunch of taka the
bunch of tacos lots of tacos which taco
experience was worth it
the caviar choco what a food it is like
little pearls of deliciousness this is
actually a hard one my worth it winner I
think it has to be casados that is next
level I mean that's like the densest
richest flavor you can get from me
they're not expensive
I mean 275 to 4500 we got guys my gas
light that's are not gonna be are we
gonna make it home we don't live
together a taco with caviar who would
have known I'm a twin ending my Orkut
learner goes to Leo's I'm surprised
because you're usually a bit of a fancy
boy to dull 25 for an incredible al
pastor taco juice is flowing everywhere
you can get gas which I need right now
and you talk about the same time what a
deal
what a steal it begs the question why we
didn't get gas because we just left
Leo's the only question left is Adam
what do you think
I win let's get some baby they don't die
your imagine obscene but diesel is
perfect they were just on the 101 just
smoking
oh yes